Hey,
so last week you talked about how you hated people ask you if you believe in God
and or do you believe miracles are,
you just liked those questions at least,
but you also talked about how,
and I want to put words in your mouth,
but I think he said something about the ideas,
an empirical evidence for religious experiences or spiritual experiences.
And I wonder how those two ideas like can a spiritual existence or can a
spiritual experience exist without God or how did I,
I had,
who knows,
who knows?
You know,
I don't know what.
I don't know what to make of that.
I mean,
you could,
it depends on what you're willing to accept as proof.
I suppose that's where things get tricky,
you know,
if you have to demonstrate the existence of God objectively than subjective
experiences of the transcendent are irrelevant.
Right?
But,
and that's a perfectly reasonable standpoint.
If your initial presupposition is the only thing that has actual existence is
those things that can be demonstrated objectively.
And I'm not putting that down.
Like that's a powerful methodology.
Our technology is basically dependent on the acceptance,
at least a partial acceptance of those axioms.
But I also think that it's difficult for me to deny the existence of these
patterns of thinking that seemed to exist cross culturally,
like the existence of the representation of the Dragon,
for example.
Especially given that I can see an evolutionary rationale for the emergence of
these representations.
So,
and then there's also the indisputable fact that religious experiences are
accessible to people through a number of different avenues.
Now,
and one of the things I mentioned when I discussed this before as well,
you could say,
well,
those are no different than experiences of psychopathology,
but they are different because the experiences of psychopathology damage people,
where's the evidence is that the transcendent experiences actually help people.
So unless you can,
unless you're willing to say,
well,
there are some forms of psychopathological experience that actually facilitate
health,
which is a possibility.
But you know,
I think you're,
you're pushing your hypo yearly hypothesis at that point.